it's been eight months of masks of
lockdowns and curfews
of living in fear of coved 19.
and around the world people are saying
they've had enough
coronavirus fatigue is setting in
not just from the virus itself but the
restrictions governments have
implemented to slow its spread
people are gathering closer together
wearing face masks less often
some of the reactions have been angry
demonstrations against coronavirus
restrictions
have drawn tens of thousands of
protesters into the streets
eight months into the pandemic we
understand that people are tired and
yearn to get on with their lives
with a vaccine likely still months away
people's desire to return to normality
and the growing backlash against
restrictions
is becoming a major risk
[Music]
after months of the pandemic it's
probably no surprise that many of us are
feeling
sick of getting sick in belgium people
are returning to school and work after
the summer break the number of new daily
cases there
is falling but the country has one of
europe's highest
death rates nevertheless a study in
dutch-speaking region
flanders home to more than half the
population shows 70 percent
of people no longer support the
restrictive measures
aimed at slowing the spread of the virus
our reporter terry shorts sent this
report
from brussels the covid 19 infection
rate is declining in belgium
but covid19 fatigue is growing
so many months of isolation so many
masks for me it's like something
really oppressive tebow who doesn't want
to give his last name
despises social distancing and defies
the rule to wear a mask in downtown
brussels
if i if i enter in the shop if i go in
the metro okay
but if i work alone in the street no no
that is
really too much and tebow is hardly
alone in his opposition
michael for stratten who represents the
protest group virus madness
says no one should have to follow
restrictions except the most vulnerable
how many people would die if we would
not take any measures at all at the
moment
we don't know in fact we have no idea
new research shows
just one in three people surveyed in the
dutch-speaking part of belgium
still supports the safety measures
that's down from more than 80 percent in
march when the pandemic first hit here
university of ghent professor martin
fanstein gustav who led the study
blames poor official communication for
the dramatic drop in motivation
he says it's been a wake-up call for
authorities to pay more attention to
people's state of mind
i don't think we have sufficiently been
informing people
on the consequences of their behavior
for them
to take a wise decision and now that
summer is over
everyone's back from holidays more
likely to be in enclosed
places at work and school it could be a
toxic coronavirus cocktail
we're quite worried leading belgian
virologist stephen van gupt
says experts are stealing for a
potential september surge
he nonetheless agrees people should be
given more information about actions and
consequences
and then more autonomy so people can
have some freedom
to choose what they think is appropriate
for their situation
and they can adapt their behavior but
are people so sick of restrictions by
now
they won't follow them vanguard believes
most
do comply i don't obey them too strictly
because it's very difficult
but i try anyway i feel much safer
wearing it we must do it all together
but skepticism is clearly growing in
recent days
open letters have been published in
belgian media signed by hundreds of
experts including doctors scientists and
researchers
suggesting the strict measures should be
reviewed
to see if they're stopping the virus or
just the vitality
of everyday life
masks always well let's speak to naomi
rogers who is professor in the history
of medicine
at yale should we be surprised that
people are starting to feel
tired of the masks and the restrictions
no i really think we shouldn't be um i
think that
uh as someone who's also
living through this as well and as a
historian of
disease um i see all around me
a sense that people have responded
pretty seriously um on the basis that
this was some kind of disaster so for a
disaster you know you hunkered down you
you follow guidance and somehow there
was an
implicit uh bargain that it would end
many parents for example worked
extraordinarily
hard with their children um restricting
their movements teaching them online
hoping assuming that come
the autumn that all the schools would be
open and everything would go back to
normal
and it's been a real shock when that is
simply not so
it's like you say there's this bargain
wasn't there if we did as we were told
then we would get an early end to this
pandemic and it's not turned out that
way for people you mentioned you're a
historian
of diseases is there a historic
precedence for this
this fatigue people getting tired of
trying to protect themselves
oh actually during the 1918 pandemic
um and and we don't know as much about
the experience of people
during pandemics as we really should
but it's very clear that people were so
anxious
to um actually to be able to celebrate
the return
of world war one um
veterans and finally at the end of what
we now know was the first
wave of the pandemic there were parades
in the street everybody was delighted
and there was also a feeling that the
pandemic had ended
but in fact that wasn't true and then
there was
um a a real sense of um
anger and frustration when uh
influenza re-emerged uh as a major
uh worldwide uh problem a second time
in just a couple of months after that so
we we do know that there have been
historical precedents both of
the idea of waves and also the
experience
of living through them yeah people are
impatient because they want this to come
to an end
but what does an end look like
how can we say when look this pandemic
is over that's such an
interesting question and i have to say
that in my experience
i've written about epidemics and i've
read widely
about others historians just didn't seem
to really problematize
that question it seems to me it's
actually quite a complicated idea
what is an end who is it who's calling
it in
when does it feel like an end
and in particular for example living
here in the united states i noticed that
um during the summer there's been a lot
of call
for the end simply to be
the end that everybody should be able to
go back to restaurants
and bars um go swimming
in uh lakes in the sea uh just return to
an ordinary happy
summer time essentially they just want
to say
this is the end that's where we are now
let's just pretend
that's exactly they're calling it the
end
um and this has been as you can imagine
resulted in great frustration by many
public health experts who say
well but it but it isn't the end and
people would
people in essence are saying we have
been
uh relatively compliant we have listened
to the science
and you don't know when the end
is um and i think that there is i i mean
i i don't know whether it's so much a
question of communication i think that's
probably one
issue but i think there's also a wider
sense
among the general public and really many
public health experts as well
which is that they don't know um
they don't really have a good sense of
um
what the end is going to look like or
how to more confidently
predict it and when you're experts
real when you realize the experts don't
know
that becomes an even greater um
motivation for just saying well maybe i
i can decide isn't it that's the problem
nobody knows
well at least this interview is now at
an end thank you naomi rogers from the
yale school of medicine it's been great
to get your insights
you're very welcome thank you for having
me
now have you got questions you'd like to
ask us about the coronavirus
well get in contact on our youtube
channel and our science correspondent
derek williams will do his best
[Music]
what country has lost the most health
care workers
this question came in a while ago and i
wanted to answer it then
but but i couldn't find reliable data
now we have some a new report
released by amnesty international last
week
revealed how the pandemic has taken a
very heavy
toll on on frontline medical staff all
over the world
in the last eight months in all
it said that at least seven thousand
health care workers
have been killed by kobet 19 worldwide
since the pandemic began and and we know
that
hundreds of thousands more have been
infected with the disease
while while making efforts to contain it
and
and to treat patients the report said
that
over half of all confirmed deaths among
medical staff
had occurred in just four countries
mexico
the united states brazil and
india that's not really a surprise
those four countries also represent more
than half of all confirmed cases of
covet 19
worldwide so so to answer your question
mexico is the country that so far seems
to have lost
the most health care workers to the
pandemic and
it's lost them at a much higher rate in
proportion to its number of confirmed
cases
than in other countries one analysis
said
healthcare workers there were four times
more likely to die of the disease
than their counterparts in the us
you